[Music]
if you're like us you are totally
obsessed with Ralph breaks the Internet
this new Disney flick is hilarious and
there were more than a few jokes that
were meant for adults
check out these ten jokes that weren't
meant for kids from the new movie do you
live for all things Disney so do we
click subscribe to stay up to date with
all things Disney alright let's check
out those ten jokes meant for adults
yeah that one's really gonna hunt me for
a while slaughter race slaughter race is
the scary violent video game that
vanellope becomes obsessed with by the
whole thing is a giant reference to a
very controversial video game it's based
on Grand Theft Auto GTA has been around
for over 20 years
and adults we'll remember how scandalous
it seemed in GTA you can do all sorts of
violent illegal stuff the adults
watching Roth breaks the internet will
recognize the game that was always under
fire from adults and activist groups at
one point we hear a player's grandma
gripe at him about playing the game and
later Ralph says it's the type of game
that rots your brain there are so many
direct references to Grand Theft Auto
that weed out younger kids picked up on
it clench your cheeks this next joke is
probably the grossest joke in the whole
movie and it also has to do with
slaughter race when vanellope and Ralph
believe the vicious video game vanellope
is pumped but Ralph was more than glad
to get out of there
vanellope describes the game as exciting
but that is not the word ralph would use
he thought it was terrifying he said
it's the kind of place that makes you
clench your cheeks he is not talking
about the cheeks on your face
Ralph is basically saying that that game
might make a person so scared that they
make a mess in their pants gross we bet
this joke flew right over the heads of
most of the kids in the audience
nostalgia the animators threw in lots of
pop-culture references holy cow
you can always stop but many of them
were meant for adults they weren't
necessarily inappropriate jokes they
were just old a couple of these came in
during the fight scene at the end the
wreck-it Ralph a virus has turned most
of the internet dark in the ruins of the
fight we see a couple of old-school
technology references there is 8-bit
diner 8-bit is a really old primitive
type of computer animation
there's also a sign for dial-up Express
back in the old days of the internet you
used to have to dial up to connect to
the internet through the phone line it
was really slow which makes calling an
Express even funnier it also made this
really terrible screeching sound kids
these days would not understand these
references Felix the dad when sugar rush
gets unplugged the game characters find
themselves homeless fix-it Felix and
Captain Calhoun decide to adopt the 15
kid racers including taffeta and rancis
but adopting 15 kids is not the way to
spice up a marriage as they're told
Felix comes to tappers and collapses on
a barstool next to Ralph Ralph says he
has never known Felix to drink root beer
root beer made just to be a soda but
they are definitely implying that it is
an adult beverage
Felix guzzles down the soda and
complains about how hard parenting is
parents everywhere will totally get
exactly what he is feeling Jay peace
family when Ralph and vanellope first
get to Ebay they are bombarded by pop-up
ads for things like getting rich by
playing video games everyone knows that
those odds are totally scams but Ralph
and vanellope are new to the internet
they connect with Jay peace family to
try to get money family comes across as
a completely shady character and he's
dressed like a classic scamming salesman
we bet all the adults have come across
scammers like spam Lee in real life he
even takes Ralph and vanellope to his
really suspicious office we know what
all those adults were thinking no don't
do it Ralph watch out for scams kids
oversized baby clothes eBay can be a
really strange place and Ralph and
vanellope figure that out pretty quickly
they go looking for the sugar rush
steering wheel but they are overwhelmed
by all the strange stuff for sale
vanellope and Ralph are pretty innocent
so when vanellope sees a sign for
lingerie she mispronounces it she says
it appears to be some sort of oversized
baby clothes but adults know that it is
the type of clothes adult women wear and
only in very adult situations if you
know what we mean this is the only
really dirty joke in the whole movie but
there are plenty of other jokes that are
not kid-friendly stay tuned for a super
violent joke Bob Ross Ralph makes a
bunch of viral videos to get money quick
one of the quick clips we see is Ralph
acting like Bob Ross Bob Ross was a
famous painter from TV in the 1980s and
1990s he's no longer around
but his shows have become popular again
on YouTube and Netflix Millennials today
love him in his calming presence older
adults will remember Bob Ross when they
see this clip but this joke was meant
for the Millennials who have started to
idolize him in the last few years we
think it's a great little tribute and
it's awesome that the creators included
jokes for all different age groups but
the kids probably won't understand this
internet is very intuitive for kids
these days the Internet has always
existed they grow up using the Internet
and a lot of times kids are better at
using the internet than adults younger
people seem to think the Internet is
very intuitive which just means it makes
perfect sense
but older people don't think that way
they didn't grow up with this sort of
technology at the searchbar Ralph's is
having a lot of trouble searching for
the sugar rush steering wheel but
vanellope who is just a kid finds it on
her first search Ralph asks how she did
it and she tells him it was easy because
the Internet is very intuitive this is
making fun of older people who have a
much harder time with the Internet
Cinderella's glass slipper one of the
most talked-about scenes from Ralph
breaks the Internet is the Disney
Princess scene it is hilarious when
Finella pee glitches and ends up in
their private room they all get ready to
attack
rapunzel has her frying pan Merida has
her arrows and Cinderella aggressively
breaks her glass slipper to use as a
weapon vanellope is totally freaked out
by this well ladies that can explain but
the joke isn't about using a shoe it's
supposed to look like Cinderella is
breaking a glass bottle of an adult
beverage to use in a bar fight and we
are talking about a happy public
choppers we're talking about a shady
violent place it's extra funny because
Cinderella does not seem like that type
of violent at all shank the head racer
and leader in slaughter race is shank
she's tough fierce and becomes a mentor
to vanellope but her whole name is a
joke about street violence a shank is
kind of a makeshift knife used in fights
her name may just sound tough to kids
but adults will understand that she's as
fierce as a street weapon she even goes
on to say shank you instead of thank you
when she's talking to vanellope
a pun but it's not super innocent
thankfully shank is more than just a
scary villain she's actually a pretty
cool character real shanks are dangerous
though yikes what was your favorite joke
in Ralph breaks the Internet sound off
in the comments and that's it for ten
jokes and Ralph breaks the internet that
were not meant for kids give this video
a big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]